the buses have been leaving every day
since the war began
this is where families say their
farewells
and the pain of these separations is
written on their faces
the red cross offers safe passage out of
odessa which could be hit at any time
like the other port cities of mariopol
and mikalive
10 million ukrainians have now fled
their homes according to the un
[Applause]
people have been coming here from across
ukraine many of them from cities that
have been attacked from here they head
west crossing the border to a safer
place
i was hugging my mom and trying to hold
back my tears
this is julia she said goodbye to her
mum today and she has no idea when
they'll be together again at least she's
somewhat safe here
the rest of the family is maripo
honestly we didn't think it's going to
be that bad
we were talking to my grandma
on the 1st of march
it was her birthday
she was born in 1943
so it would be very sad if she didn't
survive this for as well
there's no way that julia can check on
her family in mario paul not now
all she can do is save herself
i was naive enough to think that no one
would ever attack ukraine
because if you have a powerful ally
russian federation
no one would even there
it feels like a
stop to the back
i hope
people who see this
news coverage
will understand
but ukrainians are not to be blamed
we were just trying to stay
and grow as a nation in our country
we weren't invading anyone else's
country
yes it's political games is diplomacy
but right now people's lives are at
stake
this is the reality of war
thank you
and the toll that it takes on people
nick martin sky news odessa